first off the mixture take your flour
sieve really important to sieve the
flour that stops the mixture from having
any lumps in there just before you get
to the end I want to put half a teaspoon
of baking powder the baking powder gives
the mixture of some lift in and just
sift that through such a salt and pepper
next an egg about four tablespoons of
milk and give that a little whisk
now just put a little drizzle of olive
oil in there that helps to relax the
mixture we're set in make sure we got
rid of all those lumps so that I want a
nice smooth almost like a cake mixture
okay
next take the seeds out of a chili to
know the heat well with chili so give it
a really good shake tap them out slice
in half into quarter and each quarter in
half and chop through give a really nice
quick way slicing a chili into the
mixture spring onion take off that
outside layer the spring onion top and
tail slice in an angle it's a little bit
of texture running through the mixture
want that nice crunch in coriander just
slice through nice and gently you get
that in there next to sweet corn now
drain it from the tin and just Pat it
dry so doesn't make the mixture too wet
give that a nice mix
you can see now I've got 2/3 ingredients
and 1/3 of the mixture to bind together
as a cigarette or say your goodbye thing
to excite them not sort of dough pan on
olive oil in nice and hot
get a nice big dessert spoon you know
there's one nice portion in space the
fritters evenly around the pan in the
clockwise direction so you always know
which one to turn first
just with the back of your spoon sort of
spread them out a little bit okay
pilot knife just check laughter with a
color and turnover beautiful now for the
chili yogurt dressing we feed and finely
chopped of red chili and add to a pot of
natural yogurt and then some fresh lime
finish with chopped coriander
try under in give that nice mix up
chilly just lifts it the line gives it a
nice tang eNOS the fritters they smell
amazing
now with the sauce tastes fantastic that
such a delicious recipe using ITIN a
sweet core from your cupboard amazing
[Music]
if I call on the cop in olive oil you
want a really wonderful eat charred
flavor and when you toss something
really important you get all the
ingredients to the end of the pan push
down and pull back
[Music]